this is for me the line in the sand
because this is somebody who has
consistently risked it all
he has consistently been right he was
consistently praised for it
until all of a sudden he's done it with
the wrong people
hit the notification bell uh join mud
club so you get the show every single
every day
45 minutes lot of credit dot com slash
mug club it's 99 for the year you get
this hand out from 69 if you're a
student veteran active military
uh okay so let me ask you guys question
when it comes to free speech when it
comes to
comedies we'll discuss in this case when
it comes to how far you'll let the
progressive agenda be pushed what's
what's your line in the sand
the line where you go from a
conversation to you know showing them
your warface comment below i want for me
actually certainly with comedy it's norm
mcdonald so let me explain hashtag i'm
with norm
uh obviously if you haven't been
following us left pick their latest
target
they successfully protested norm to the
point that he was canceled uh from
tonight's show
and to be fair he then said that he
actually withdrew because everyone was
crying and fallon came back he did an
interview with howard stern was very
tactful that's beside the point
this is why there was the the outrage in
the first place i think that's what's
most important you know marlo was had to
begin with
his comment was yeah i'm happy that uh
hashtag the me too moving to slowed down
a little bit it used to be uh
100 women can't be lying you know and
then it became one woman can't lie
and that became i believe all woman and
you're like
what that's the exact quote and
and make the case why i actually think
it should be
everybody's to a degree or certainly he
should be in your rush your rushmore of
faces as far as lines
let me state this emphatically nor
mcdonald is the most important voice
in all of comedy today period bar none
of course you precious of course now
norm is way funnier than me no it just
it hurt to hear it
no you're right but norm is funnier than
almost he is
why is it so important and we'll get
into norm's history if you haven't a lot
of people in our generation don't really
appreciate just
how how much of a trailblazer he is i
think he's the most important comedic
voice honestly since lenny bruce if you
look at his catalog and you look at the
influence you look at the impact and
specific decisions
we've talked about kind of moments where
the culture pivoted norm was a catalyst
for a lot of those
and if the left the progressive left
silences nor macdonald
successfully the entire landscape of
comedy changes forever
this is comedians and addicts getting
porridge
so the ss says i've never paid 25
dollars for a garbanzo bean
[Music]
it's important okay have you heard
someone
about the gestapo who goes into the bar
okay
[Music]
i'll say
dude that's so funny all right thank you
good editing boys you good job right
when you finally got uh you you got the
german
down before when it started remember we
started doing this he was sounding like
adam sandler for some reason
i can't do german i can't do anything
i don't want to do garbage okay so
you're thinking at one point you'd find
everyone in the industry to agree but
this outrage this protest was no
it's been a long time brewing yeah
norma's always been known for speaking
truth to power but lately he's kind of
been under the radar unfortunately for
the left but fortunately for us
pushing all of the right buttons you see
it here well because i think she's the
most
corrupt uh person that we've ever had in
the white house
i mean right there's there's so many um
terrible things that she's done that we
forget but there was one
that i don't know why this was swept
under the rug but you know she went into
the irs
uh and and looked at political enemies
um
tax returns and something will continue
he knows exactly
why but yeah i don't know i don't know
uh why he knows exactly why the guy has
an
unbelievable iq he's an actual genius
and he is actually
putting a finer point on what we know to
be uh completely true of comedy in the
era of trump but he vocalizes it he just
he crystallizes it perfectly it's more
difficult
in the time of trump for good comedians
and it's
way easier for bad comedians you know
you don't have a worldview
by just saying you don't like trump you
know what i mean that doesn't count like
you can't you can't just say i hate
trump
and and that makes you a good person and
uh
the democrats just can't say i hate
trump and that means they have a
position
you know that's not a position uh so
so for uh for idiots it's an easier time
because
you go well that guy's uh that guy's the
idiot not me
speaking this sort of this generality
but yeah okay what kind of comedians do
you think he's speaking
about specifically if you mentally add
it up at every turn he continues to
remind us that he is just fundamentally
unfit for the job of the president he is
thinking that by acting crazy
to strengthen rex's hand with the
negotiations you know it's the old
good cause hillary lost a real president
doesn't write books
they write tweets i don't know how that
chamber now has this show i thought he
was uh
too busy kicking out white farmers
the left constantly talks about bravery
norm just fired a shot over the bow of
every single gatekeeper in the business
in which he makes a living palsy that's
what this is about
the reason and i i actually mean that
hashtag i'm with norm is so important to
me is because
whether norm mcdonald admits or not he
probably never would
he's always been a person compelled to
speak truth against corrupt authority do
you remember the reason he was fired
from snl a lot of people again in this
generation don't necessarily know you
remember that whole debacle yeah he's
one of my heroes
for many reasons but this was one of
this one as a kid same thing for me i
was talking about my dad would would
videotape letterman so i remember seeing
seeing an interview with norm where he
talked about this it was because of dan
olmeyer i think is how pronounced
unfortunately he's not he's not with us
anyway was the executive nbc he was
buddies with oj
and and he didn't want norm to keep
doing the o.j michael jackson jokes
they warned him remember they said don't
do the o.j and michael jackson jokes
they asked him
these were the people with his paycheck
they said don't do this
and by the way we all saw how that
turned out in his book
o.j simpson says that he would have
taken a bullet or stood in front of a
train for nicole
man i'm gonna tell you that is some bad
luck when the one guy who would have
died for you
kills you he became the first defensive
player to win the heisman trophy
congratulations charlotte
that is something that no one can ever
take away from you
unless you kill your wife and a waiter
in which case
look at the guy look at one guy's upset
no man i ain't even about that
have decided to skip hearings on dna
evidence and go right to trial
ask why they did this the lawyers
replied we want to get oj acquitted as
speedily as possible so he can get back
to doing what he does best
killing people michael jackson
he said i heard a quote where he said he
he said i don't care
if uh my child is a boy or a girl
as long as it's a boy
he's gonna name it he said he doesn't
know what he's gonna name him he said he
said he thinks if it's a girl
he's gonna name it uh sharon really
yeah and if it's a boy he's going to
have sex with him
i love it i love it because he's
relentlessly beating a society over the
head for stuff that we all know is true
right yeah it's like when no comic would
make fun of caitlyn jenner being woman
of the year
it's like i was just like someone yeah
that's what i said remember that the
reaction that one guy was like oh like
what you're racist you're offended
yeah and i wonder if that guy nowadays
looks back and goes
man you know i did kind of get screwed
with the if i did it book
i do look kind of dumb here's something
else you know
the reason i'm showing that these are
long clips i want this pounded into your
skull
as to how important norm has been in the
landscape of comedy and how people we
use the term fearless i don't know if
he's fearless i don't know if he's
afraid before he goes on these shows or
not but if we're going to
use the term bravery norm is comedy
bravery personified he was banned from
the view for a long time you know why
because of this joke he made about bill
clinton being a murderer
i think we should get the homicide out
of the white house
and get like a a fresh start because we
don't want any more murderers
i think we should just go on to the next
question he was murderous
oh clinton he murdered a guy yeah you
know
i'm not going to ask the next i thought
it was a matter of recording
i thought you were supposed to be funny
oh thanks because yeah we're relying on
you
we spoke about norm not long ago yeah
and uh we were looking for that clip we
couldn't find it anywhere on youtube
about a year and a half ago i remember
it
we searched for about three hours until
we just had to say okay we're going to
have to scrap this
it was scrubbed from youtube
incredibly ballsy from a guy who this
industry they have all the money and
they have all the power
what do we do the only thing that we can
do really is just not does colin
kaepernick sacrifice
exactly this guy has consistently at
least been willing to sacrifice anything
and lost his job
at the biggest most hip comedy show on
television at that point in
at that point in time in the 90s this
guy can say he went away for a long time
a lot of people oh what is norm up to
except in the world of comedy he's been
a comedians comedian for a long time the
reason that hashtag i'm with norm which
is what i'm calling is so important
he's not just a comedian he's a
veritable authoritarianism
weather stick he is a comedian with the
single most stellar track record
for speaking con using comedy uh to
shine a light on
on the real taboos of our time you know
here to simplify it
if norm mcdonald is pushing back against
something that
tells you that it's wrong whatever it
may be he's almost always right he's
batting a thousand
he is he is yeah like if you go back in
time you start realizing how
stupid we were in certain points in
history
where we would go along with nonsense
right well here's the best part too
i know that you'll you'll appreciate
particularly you not so much but you
know
unlike samantha bee unlike seth meyers
norm speaks not not just through outrage
not through protests
not through bumping elbows with the
right politicians at correspondent
stinners every single year but through
funny yeah it's why for decades
comedians have you know a lot of
they've com there is almo you know
people use the term consensus
as far as yeah consensus doesn't
determine science but
consensus when it comes to a comedian
it's very very hard to get on comedy
and norm from those who practice comedy
they unilaterally agree
he's as good as anyone's ever been to
this day i've never interviewed anybody
like norman mcdonald
very talented actor
nobody funnier ladies and gentlemen norm
mcdonald
and now you have today's non-comedian
comedians they're all coming for them it
shows us who they this is why this is so
important the norms
it shows us exactly who they are and it
shows us where the real cultural
censorship lies
i'm typically not in the business of
hashtags or movements and the same with
a lot of people on the right are but i
would ask
everyone to comment below tweet
instagram norm that
you're with him you have to be
hashtagging with norm but if he's
playing in your city go see him
watch his show just let him see that you
support him because right now he's being
surrounded by people in this
industry who are letting him know that
he has to apologize or letting him know
that people
jimmy fallon talking about people coming
and crying for his metoo comments
so i need it is important that he see
that you guys are out there and i know
he'll probably play it off and it'll
probably be embarrassed by the support
but let me restate this here if the left
successfully silences nor mcdonald's in
any capacity
everything could be lost why because
this right now to me is the most
egregious blatant example of the left
taking someone out
for using their words worse taking a
comedian out
for using his words worse taking a
comedian out specifically for using his
words against
them the leftist mob kneecapping norm
mcdonald is
is petrifying to me because in the past
you have taken people into the back room
and roughed them up in the shadows right
like like
you were dropped by uh you're i know i
was dropped by my manager agent was it
your manager
manager and agent for me saying that uh
there's no trans kids
and hormone blockers are bad and my
agent was like
if you apologize publicly uh we'll we'll
keep you at caa i'm like
are you intentionally trying to be
biblical yeah
i have the same thing with the world for
my soul are you doing that on purpose
with a guy named eli and he called me i
swear to you i don't know if you're
doing like a cold bear thing with being
so right now
you you can't comprehend someone being
moderately traditionally conservative
like myself i'm not
that far right dude my agent's name was
judas it should have been a sign the
writing was on the wall
the reason i think this is so important
is that it used to be like you know
behind the scenes your manager your
agent would drop you you wouldn't be
invited to the dinners right you got
excluded from all the talk shows
but now if if they successfully carry
out this execution against
norm that's exactly what it is it's
equivalent to a public execution right
in the middle of the street it's just
left they're so scared often we say if
they would be so bold or if this
person's so scared
often scared people make bold moves
because they're cowards
even worse when they're in a mob and
that's what you see with the left it
shows us that the left is so scared
they'll do anything to silence criticism
even if you see the mild comments from
nor macdonald and me too it isn't about
shining a light on the left's motorcycle
anymore
we've already done that i know you've
already done that norm's already done
that they don't care
they don't care this is they're not even
trying to keep it a secret that's what's
so startling to me
this nor macdonald what they're doing
right now
is about punishment it's about the left
trying to make a public example of him
and when it comes to the free speech
fight
when it comes to the the direction i
want to see for comedy when it comes to
the gaggle of late night hosts comedians
executives producers
their media brethren and their symbiotic
leftist
hate mob and the blatant attempt to
silence any dissent
this is for me the line in the sand
because this is somebody who has
consistently risked it all
he has consistently been right he was
consistently praised for it
until all of a sudden he's done it with
the wrong this is why hashtag
i'm with norman
the gestapo did nothing he was very
pleasant
and i clearly had the moral superiority
and very brave
he was very brave but that's not even
funny though
hey there youtube viewer if you like
this video i would say subscribe hit the
notification bell
or watch one of these videos playing in
a box that we've personally uploaded and
programmed for your viewing pleasure the
problem is now
in today's day and age on youtube in
2018 any of those three things that you
do any of those three buttons that you
click will take you directly to a seth
meyer's video
so stay here and join get off of here go
to lotto credit.com it's the only safe
place you can go
and join